Tu t'mets l'cambouis sur les mains
Ou tu mets le cap sur les îles
Une mauvaise note au destin
Ou un bon point si c'est facile
T'es dans la rue dans la ville
Un walkman collé sur l'nombril
Enfant noir femme de Toulouse
Tous ceux qui chantent : I was born to loose
Joueurs de blues
On est des joueurs de blues
Joueurs de blues, on est des joueurs de blues
Joueurs de blues
On est des joueurs de blues
Trafiquants d'armes ou douaniers
Cousteau Bombard ou Caroline
Un sage assis sous un cerisier
Mère Teresa frère Luther King
Tu plais t'emballes et tu frimes
Ou t'attends la mort et tu trimes
Le Blanc qui chante Toulouse
Le Noir qui chante : I was born to loose
Joueurs de blues
On est des joueurs de blues
Joueurs de blues on est des joueurs de blues
Joueurs de blues
On est des joueurs de blues
Mecs de La Mecque gars d'la Garonne
Salut Pepita où est l'sherif que j'l'assomme
( à l'origine : "Souffleur de verre, souffle
dans le saxophone")
Belle marquise, Mesrine belle baronne
Mille et mille et mille et mille millions
d'personnes
Joueurs de blues
On est des joueurs de blues